This episode is sponsored by Newport Health Care, providing results-driven treatment for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with trauma, depression, anxiety, and co-occurring issues like eating disorders and substance abuse. Newport's trauma-informed programs incorporate experiential activities like adventure therapy, mixed martial arts, dance, and yoga, because we know that moving the body benefits the mind. Learn more at Newport Healthcare.com. More than one in four American adults is physically inactive, according to a report in January, from the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention. That means they don't participate in any leisure time physical activities, such as jogging, walking for exercise, or even gardening. And even those among us who spend some time moving probably aren't spending enough.
本集节目由Newport Healthcare赞助播出，我们为正在经历创伤、抑郁、焦虑以及饮食失调和药物滥用等共病问题的12至28岁青少年和年轻人提供结果导向的治疗。Newport以创伤知情为基础的项目融合了探险疗法、综合格斗、舞蹈和瑜伽等体验式活动，因为我们深知身体运动有益于心理健康。欢迎访问Newport Healthcare.com了解详情。根据美国疾病控制与预防中心今年1月的一份报告，超过四分之一的美国成年人缺乏身体活动。这意味着他们不参加任何休闲时间的体育活动，例如慢跑、健身散步甚至园艺。即便是我们当中那些花了一些时间活动的人，运动量可能也远远不够。
Around 60% of U.S. adults don't get the recommended amount of physical. activity in their daily lives. Most people realize that being sedentary is bad for our health. Lack of exercise raises a person's risk of heart disease, diabetes, and many other chronic ailments. But scientists are also increasingly interested in how exercise or the lack of it can affect our cognitive health. So what's the connection between exercise and thinking or cognition? Can movement build memory as well as muscle? Does staying physically fit reduce our risk of dementia, and if so how, and are some types of exercise better than others? Given what we know about the benefits of physical activity, what's the best way to encourage
大约有60%的美国成年人在日常生活中没有达到推荐的身体活动量。大多数人意识到久坐不动有害健康。缺乏锻炼会增加一个人患心脏病、糖尿病以及许多其他慢性疾病的风险。但科学家们也越来越感兴趣于锻炼或缺乏锻炼将如何影响我们的认知健康。那么，锻炼与思考或认知之间有什么联系呢？运动能否像强健肌肉一样增强记忆力？保持身体健康能降低我们患痴呆症的风险吗？如果是的话，又是如何实现的？某些类型的运动是否比其他运动更好？鉴于我们对身体活动益处的了解，鼓励儿童和成年人保持活跃的最佳方法是什么？
kids and adults to stay active? And if you've been leading a sedentary life, how can you get yourself moving? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Jenny Etneyer, a professor in the Department of Kinesiology at the University of North Carolina Greensboro. Dr. Etnier's research focuses on the cognitive benefits of physical activity from childhood through adulthood.
如果你一直过着久坐少动的生活，又该如何让自己动起来？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客节目，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是北卡罗来纳大学格林斯伯格分校（University of North Carolina Greensboro）运动学系的詹妮·埃特尼尔（Dr. Jenny Etnier）教授。埃特尼尔教授的研究重点是从儿童期到成年期身体活动对认知的益处。
She's currently leading a study on the effects of physical activity on middle-aged adults at risk for Alzheimer's disease. She's also a lifelong athlete and youth sport coach, and she's written two books for the general public about those topics, bring your A-game a young athlete's guide to mental toughness, and coaching for the love of the game, a practical guide for working with young athletes. She's a fellow of the American College of Sports Medicine and the National Academy of Kinesiology, and was the president of the North American Society for the Psychology of Sport and Physical Activity. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Ettingeyer. Oh, thank you so much for having me. It's my pleasure, and thanks for that
她目前正在领导一项关于身体活动对有患阿尔茨海默病风险的中年成年人影响的研究。她本人也是一名终身运动员和青少年体育教练，并围绕这些主题为普通大众写了两本书：《发挥出你的最佳水平：年轻运动员的心理韧性指南》（Bring Your A-Game: A Young Athlete's Guide to Mental Toughness）以及《为了对运动的热爱而执教：与年轻运动员合作的实用指南》（Coaching for the Love of the Game: A Practical Guide for Working with Young Athletes）。她是美国运动医学会（American College of Sports Medicine）和国家运动学学院（National Academy of Kinesiology）的院士，曾任北美运动与身体活动心理学协会（North American Society for the Psychology of Sport and Physical Activity）的主席。欢迎参加我们的节目，埃特尼尔博士。哦，非常感谢邀请我来。我很荣幸，也谢谢你做出的那些非常友好的介绍。
really kind introduction. You're welcome. What types of cognitive benefits have you looked for and what have you found and what evidence do we have that physical activity helps our brains as well as our bodies? Yeah, that's a great question. And it's a surprisingly robust body of evidence that really supports the idea that being physically active can benefit your cognition, your ability to perform thinking types of tasks, really broadly. Now, that being said, there is some evidence that suggest that where we see the biggest effects are on tasks that measure things that are referred to as executive functions. And those are the types of higher order mental processing skills that really allow us to be successful in our everyday living. So executive function tasks are
不客气。你寻找过哪些类型的认知益处？又发现了什么？我们有什么证据表明身体活动既对我们的大脑有益，也对我们的身体有益？是的，这是一个很好的问题。而且，这是一个令人惊讶的强有力的证据基础，它确实支持了这样一种观点，即保持身体活动可以广泛地有话你的认知以及执行思考类型任务的能力。话虽如此，确实有一些证据表明，我们看到最大影响的任务是那些测量被称为执行功能的任务。这些是更高阶的心理处理技能，确实能让我们在日常生活中取得成功。所以，执行功能任务是
things like working memory, your ability to hold things in your mind and manipulate those things to answer some sort of a question. Inhibition would be like, you know, if the light turns green, you hold on for that second to wait and make sure that the cross-traffic isn't coming, right? And so tasks like that that are executive function, we know are benefited by exercise. And then in my lab group, we've really focused a lot on memory and looking at episodic memory, which the way we measure it in a lab-based format is simply to ask people to remember a list of words and test their ability to do so. So what actually happens in the brain during exercise that benefits cognition?
诸如工作记忆之类的事情，也就是你在脑海中保持信息并操纵这些信息来回答某种问题的能力。抑制控制就像是，你知道的，如果灯变绿了，你暂停那一秒钟等待并确保横向交通没有驶来，对吧？因此，我们知道像这样属于执行功能的任务会从锻炼中受益。而在我的实验室团队中，我们真正重点关注的是记忆以及情景记忆。我们在基于实验室的格式中衡量它的方式非常简单，就是要求人们记住一串单词并测试他们这样做的能力。那么，在锻炼期间大脑中究竟发生了什么，从而有利于认知呢？
We don't know exactly yet. We do have some hints to things that are happening. So there are these substances in the brain called neurotrophic factors. And I sort of think of those as factors that work together to prune synapses and neurons that are not needed for cognitive performance and to also bolster kind of provide miracle grow for those synapses and neurons that we do need to perform cognitive performance. So what we believe happens, or one way that we think exercise might benefit cognition, is because of its impact on these neurotrophic factors, impacting them in a way that then benefits our ability to perform well cognitively. Now, when I said that, Kim, I was sort of thinking about a single session of exercise. There's also a lot of research that looks at repetitive performance of physical activity about so chronic exercise. And when we think about the mechanisms there, now we're thinking about actual changes to brain structure that can then benefit cognitive performance.
我们目前还不是很清楚。我们确实有一些关于正在发生的事情的线索。大脑中存在着被称为神经营养因子的物质。我某种程度上把这些因子看作是共同起作用的因子，它们一方面修剪掉对认知表现不需要的突触和神经元，另一方面也为我们执行认知表现真正需要的突触和神经元提供类似于“奇迹生长”的支持。因此，我们认为发生的情况，或者我们认为锻炼可能有利于认知的途径之一，是因为它对这些神经营养因子的影响，这种影响以某种方式进而有益于我们良好执行认知任务的能力。金，当我刚才那样说的时候，我其实是在考虑单次锻炼。还有很多研究着眼于重复进行的身体活动，也就是长期锻炼。当我们思考其中的机制时，现在我们考虑的是对大脑结构的实际改变，这反过来可以使认知表现受益。
And do we know what structures are changing? Are you still looking at that? No. I mean, the evidence is really growing quickly, but for sure there is evidence that we see changes in hippocampus, which many of your listeners may know is really important for cognitive performance and specifically for memory. So you've said that you take a developmental or lifespan approach to your work, that you're interested in the benefits of physical activity from childhood through adulthood. Can you talk about that? Are there more benefits or different benefits at some life stages than at others? Yeah, I actually love that we've been able to do that in our research that we've done here at UNCG. We've done research with kids, with young, college-aged adults, and then also with middle-aged and older adults. In the work I'm going to tell you about right now, it's been looking at the benefits of a single session of exercise for these various age groups. And we find that there are benefits across the lifespan. So we've done, I think it's really fun work from my point of view, but we've gone out to the schools, and we've looked at kids in middle school who are doing physical activity as a part of their physical education curriculum. And as soon as they've finished a physical activity bout, we've assessed their memory.
我们知道哪些结构在改变吗？你们还在研究这个吗？不是的。我的意思是，证据确实在快速增长，但可以肯定的是，有证据表明我们在海马体中看到了改变。你的许多听众可能知道，海马体对认知表现，特别是对记忆非常重要。你曾说过，你在工作中采取了发展或终生视角，你对从童年到成年整个生命周期中身体活动的益处很感兴趣。你能谈谈这个吗？在某些生命阶段，益处会比其他阶段更多或有所不同吗？是的，我其实很高兴我们能够在我们在UNCG（北卡罗来纳大学格林斯伯格分校）开展的研究中做到这一点。我们对儿童、年轻的大学年龄段成年人，以及中年和老年成年人进行了研究。我接下来要告诉你的这项研究，一直是在观察单次锻炼对这些不同年龄组的益处。我们发现，在整个人生阶段都有益处。所以我们做过，从我的角度来看，我认为这是非常有趣的工作。我们去到学校，观察了正在将身体活动作为体育课程一部分的中学儿童。就在他们完成一次身体活动后，我们对他们的记忆进行了评估。
And then we've assessed their memory on a day when they haven't done the physical activity bout. And we find that the physical activity benefits their ability to perform these memory tests that we're using. Well, we see that in our laboratory with young adults, and we've seen that in the laboratory as well with middle-aged and older adults. We do think that we get slightly bigger benefits for the older adults and that we can also see them stronger benefits depending on when the exercise is. is administered. So, Kim, if I were to ask you to remember a list of 15 words and then to tell me back how many you can remember, I could ask you to exercise before I tell you the list or right after I tell you the list. And what we found is that with older adults, we get benefits even if they exercise after hearing the list. So it's helping not just with encoding of the words when they're
然后，我们在他们没有进行身体活动的那天评估了他们的记忆力。我们发现，身体活动有利于提高他们执行我们正在使用的这些记忆测试的能力。我们在实验室里对年轻人进行了研究，在实验室里对中年人和老年人也看到了这一点。我们确实认为，老年人会获得更大的益处，并且根据锻炼实施的时机，我们还可以看到更强的益处。所以，金，如果我要求你记住15个单词的列表，然后告诉我你能记住多少，我可以在我告诉你这个列表之前让你锻炼，或者就在我告诉你这个列表之后让你锻炼。我们发现，对于老年人来说，即使他们在听到列表后锻炼，我们也能获得益处。因此，它不仅有助于在首次听到单词时的编码，而且对于老年人来说，它可能还有助于巩固这种记忆，以便24小时后当我们要求他们回忆这些单词时，他们能做得更好。
first heard, but for older adults, it may also be helping with the consolidation of that memory so that 24 hours later when we ask them to remember the words, they do a better job. So how fit do you have to be to see cognitive benefits? Is there a minimum amount of exercise that we need to do? And is there a ceiling? So if you exercise to a certain level, you're not going to see any more benefits if you run marathons than if you run 10Ks. Yeah, that's an interesting question, Kim. And again, I know I keep coming back to this, but I guess it depends on if the question is about a single session of exercise or if we're thinking about like a commitment to.
那么，你的身体需要有多健康才能看到认知益处？我们是否需要进行最低限度的锻炼？是否存在一个上限？所以，如果你锻炼到某个特定水平，跑马拉松获得的益处会不会并不比跑10公里获得更多？是的，这是一个有趣的问题，金。再次说明，我知道我一直在回到这一点上，但我想这取决于问题是关于单次锻炼，还是关于对锻炼的某种承诺。
exercise. With single sessions of exercise, most of the research has demonstrated that the effects, the benefits are reliably seen if you exercise between 20 and 30 minutes at moderate intensity. There are some studies where they've looked at like high intensity interval training and also seen cognitive benefits. But most people, I think, would probably suggest that running a marathon is going to lead to more fatigue, and so you may not see those cognitive benefits as clearly. When we're talking about sort of a lifelong commitment to exercise, then we really have evidence that suggests that doing something is enough.
对于单次锻炼，大多数研究表明，如果你以中等强度锻炼20到30分钟，就能可靠地看到效果和益处。有些研究探讨了诸如高强度间歇训练之类的内容，也看到了认知益处。但我认为，大多数人可能会建议，跑马拉松会导致更多的疲劳，因此你可能无法那么清楚地看到那些认知益处。当我们谈论对锻炼的终生承诺时，我们确实有证据表明，做点什么就已经足够了。
So getting off the couch and starting to walk and making that a part of your daily regimen, that can make the difference. those benefits probably do plateau after a certain point in time, you know, after a certain amount, volume that you're doing. And so the people who are training for marathons are probably not getting additional benefits compared to those who are doing, really just meeting physical activity guidelines. What about for people who have been sedentary for a long time and then they start to exercise regularly, maybe for the first time in their lives, but they waited until their 40s or their 50s or beyond? will you still see the same level of benefit to their cognition? Yeah, I don't know if I can answer that perfectly, Kim, because thinking of that group, you might have some who exercise regularly through their 20s
因此，离开沙发，开始走路，并将其作为你日常生活的一部分，就能带来改变。你知道的，在达到一定的时间点后，在完成一定的运动量之后，这些益处可能会趋于平稳。因此，那些为马拉松进行训练的人，与那些真正只是达到身体活动指南要求的人相比，可能不会获得额外的益处。那么，对于那些长期久坐，然后开始定期锻炼的人来说呢？也许是他们一生中第一次锻炼，但他们等到了40岁、50岁或更大年龄时才开始，你是否仍然会看到对他们认知的同等水平的益处？是的，金，我不知道我是否能完美地回答这个问题，因为考虑到那一群体，你可能会有一些人在整个20多岁时都在定期锻炼
and then stopped for 10 years or 5 years or whatever, and you may have some who have been sedentary their whole lives. I certainly think there's a benefit to exercising across the lifespan, so I'm a huge advocate of trying to get our kids to be physically active, I'm a huge advocate of keeping our college students physically active. It's really hard to maintain your physical activity when you have major life changes. So when you go from high school to college, maybe your behavior changes. When you go from college to your first job or when you go from high school to your first job,
然后中断了10年、5年或其他时间，你也可能会有一些人一辈子都久坐不动。我当然认为在整个生命周期中锻炼是有益的，所以我大力提倡让我们的孩子保持身体活动，我也大力提倡让我们的大学生保持身体活动。当你经历重大的生活变故时，要维持你的身体活动其实非常困难。因此，当你从高中升入大学时，也许你的行为会发生改变。当你从大学步入第一份工作，或者当你从高中步入第一份工作时，
maybe your behavior changes. I think you were kind of mentioning 40-year-olds, and so I think about them and I think, okay, so now they've got school-aged kids. And so their free time is probably focused on their children more than their own physical activity. So let me try to get back to your question now. If somebody has been sedentary for an extended period of time, we have evidence that shows that if they begin to be physically active, they can still experience cognitive benefits. if they're going to be relatively permanent benefits, then the physical activity has to be engaged in in a more enduring way.
也许你的行为会发生改变。我想你刚才有点提到40岁的人，所以我想到他们时就会觉得，好吧，现在他们有了学龄儿童。因此，他们的空闲时间可能更多地集中在孩子身上，而不是他们自己的身体活动上。所以，让我试着回到你的问题上来。如果某人长期处于久坐状态，我们有证据表明，如果他们开始进行身体活动，他们仍然可以体验到认知益处。如果这些将是相对持久的益处，那么必须以更持久的方式参与身体活动。
But you could still get benefits from a single session of exercise on something that you were doing in the very short term, a cognitive task in the very short term. Let me change gears a little bit, and we're still talking about the brain, of course. In the past few years, there's been a lot of buzz and some controversy around brain training games and the benefits of doing things like crossword puzzles to keep our minds sharp.
但你仍然可以通过单次锻炼获得针对短期内正在做的事情的益处，即非常短期的认知任务。让我稍微转换一下话题，当然，我们仍在讨论大脑。在过去的几年里，关于大脑训练游戏以及通过做诸如纵横字谜之类的事情来保持我们思维敏捷的益处，有很多炒作和一些争议。
How do the benefits of physical activity compare with these types of mental exercises? Yeah, I mean, there is some evidence that some forms of brain training can benefit cognitive performance. What's typically shown, then, is shown, though, is that it's pretty limited in scope. And so if you do crossword puzzles, you can probably guess, you'll improve. at doing crossword puzzles. If you're doing some sort of a stop and go task, you'll improve at doing stop and go tasks. What's nice about physical activity is that the benefits are much broader than that. So by being physically active, as I mentioned right at the beginning, we expect that you're going to see benefits across a variety of cognitive tasks, not just on specific ones that you've
身体活动的益处与这些类型的心理锻炼相比如何？是的，我的意思是，确实有一些证据表明某些形式的大脑训练可以使认知表现受益。然而，通常显示出来的是，它的范围相当有限。因此，如果你做纵横字谜，你可能会猜到，你的纵横字谜能力会提高。如果你在做某种“红灯绿灯”式的任务，你的这类任务能力就会提高。身体活动的好处在于，它的益处要广泛得多。因此，正如我在一开始就提到的，通过保持身体活动，我们预计你会看到各种认知任务的益处，而不仅仅是在你练习过的特定任务上。
practiced. Are there particular types of exercise that are more beneficial than others when it comes to cognitive improvement? Most of the research has been done with aerobic activity, walking, you know, maybe jogging even. But there are some studies where they've combined aerobic exercise with strength training. The national guidelines recommend strength training for all of us on a regular basis. And so typically what we'll see is that the results are, the benefits are bigger when somebody does something that's a combination of both aerobic training and strength training. Let me add one more thing, Kim, I'm sorry, but I was also going to say there's an intriguing new line of research that's thinking about how you can make aerobic exercise or strength training itself cognitively engaging. So that's something that I find really fascinating.
在认知改善方面，是否存在某些特定类型的运动比其他运动更有益？大多数研究都是针对有氧运动进行的，比如散步，甚至可能是慢跑。但也有一些研究将有氧运动与力量训练结合起来。国家指南建议我们所有人定期进行力量训练。因此，通常情况下我们会看到，当一个人进行结合了有氧训练和力量训练的混合运动时，结果会更好，益处会更大。金，请允许我补充一点，抱歉，我原本还想说，有一个引人入胜的新研究方向正在思考如何让有氧运动或力量训练本身就具有认知吸引力。所以这是我发现非常着迷的事情。
I haven't had an opportunity to research it myself as yet. But, you know, you sort of consider a person who goes walking with a friend or a family member, and while they're walking, they're conversing. So they're listening to one another. They're responding in an appropriate way. They're social skills that are involved and challenged compared to somebody who's walking at the same speed on a treadmill with no cognitive engagement. And to be, I think that's a fascinating direction for future research is to envision how we might combine cognitive engagement with the physical activity that we're doing in a way that might allow you to see bigger benefits. And so an ancillary to that then would be to say, okay, well, what if you're like doing dance? What if you're doing some sort of a dance program?
我还没有机会亲自去研究它。但是，你知道的，你可以设想一个人和朋友或家人一起散步，在散步的同时他们在交谈。所以他们在倾听彼此。他们在以合适的方式做出回应。与一个在跑步机上以相同速度行走且没有认知参与的人相比，其中涉及并挑战了社交技能。对我而言，我认为这是未来研究的一个迷人方向，即设想我们如何将认知参与与我们正在进行的身体活动结合起来，这种方式可能会让你看到更大的益处。因此，这的一个辅助方面就是说，好吧，那么如果跳舞呢？如果某种舞蹈节目呢？
Now you're having to think about a rhythm and a beat and staying in tune to it and maybe matching your movements to a partner. And so you're getting aerobic exercise, but in this really cognitively engaging way. And I mean, to my mind, that raises the question of whether you're, say, walking and listening to music or walking and listening to a book or a podcast or something that's going to be more engaging that requires. requires you to pay attention. Are you looking at that? I'm not personally, but I think that's an important direction for future research, because I think that's really interesting. And the other piece that brings into, Kim, Kim, is to think about, you know, I've said several times, like the longer commitment to physical activity, if you can do it in a chronic way and an enduring way, then you're more likely to get these long-term benefits.
现在你必须考虑节奏和拍子，保持与之合拍，也许还要把你的动作与舞伴相匹配。所以你得到了有氧运动，但却是以这种非常具有认知参与性的方式获得的。我的意思是，在我看来，这就引发了一个问题：如果你在散步时听音乐，或者在散步时听书或播客，或者听一些需要你专心听取、更有吸引力的东西，会怎么样呢？你们在研究这个吗？我个人没有，但我认为这是未来研究的一个重要方向，因为我认为这真的很有趣。金，这也带来了另一个方面，你知道的，我曾多次说过，比如对身体活动的更长期承诺，如果你能以长期和持久的方式进行，那么你更有可能获得这些长期益处。
Well, the only way that we're going to do physical activity in an enduring way is if we enjoy it. So, you know, this notion of listening to podcasts or listening to music or walking with a partner, those are all techniques that allow people or encourage people to increase their adherence to their walking plan. So there's that added benefit as well in addition to potentially being more cognitively engaging and so accruing more cognitive benefits. And now we're going to take a short break. This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, dedicated to providing accessible and ethical treatment to young people. ages 12 to 28, who are struggling with mental health concerns and behavioral health issues, including depression, anxiety, and substance abuse. Newport offers a full continuum of care for
好吧，我们能够以持久方式进行身体活动的唯一方法就是我们喜欢它。所以，你知道的，这种听播客、听音乐或与伴侣一起散步的概念，都是允许人们或鼓励人们增加对步行计划依从性的技术。因此，除了可能更具认知吸引力从而积累更多认知益处之外，还有这种额外的益处。现在我们要进行短暂的休息。本集节目由Newport Healthcare赞助播出，我们致力于为12至28岁正在与心理健康问题和行为健康问题（包括抑郁、焦虑和药物滥用）做斗争的年轻人提供包容和符合道德的治疗。Newport为青少年和年轻人提供全方位的关怀，
teens and young adults using a whole-person approach that incorporates physical activity as an essential element of well-being. Each client's tailored treatment plan includes somatic and experiential modalities to tap into the power of the mind-body connection to create sustainable healing. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. So as I mentioned in the intro, another area where you've done a lot of work is on youth sports. And now that spring is here and kids are trying out for little league or maybe the youth swim team at their community pool, I wanted to go back and talk about that. You wrote an op-ed in the New York Times a couple of years ago called your kids coach is probably doing it wrong. That was a real attention grabber. And what did you mean by it? Since about
采用全人方法，将身体活动纳入其中，作为幸福感的重要组成部分。每个客户量身定制的治疗方案都包括躯体和体验式疗法，以发掘身心连接的力量，从而实现可持续的康复。了解更多信息请访问newporthealthcare.com。正如我在开场白中所提到的，你做过大量工作的另一个领域是青少年体育。既然春天已经到来，孩子们正在选拔小联盟或者社区游泳池的青少年游泳队，我想回过头来谈谈这个。几年前你在《纽约时报》上写过一篇专栏文章，题为《你的孩子教练可能做错了》。那真是一个吸引眼球的标题。你是什么意思？自从大约
45 million kids participate in youth sports today, what could their coaches be doing better? I think, you know, in the second book that I wrote Coaching for the Love of the Game, I think, you know, I just, I really want to emphasize to coaches who are often, you know, volunteer parent coaches, just to remind them of why they're coaching in the first place, why you signed your child up for this sport in the first place. And I think we tend to get distracted as parents, as coaches, by all of the emphasis that is put on winning and success and outcome in professional sports and in college sports. And, you know, your listeners will all be in tune to this, that there is a concern that youth sport has sort of become a mini college or professional sport venue where parents and kids, and coaches start to put too much emphasis on winning and skill development and, you know, playing at a higher level.
现在有4500万儿童参与青少年体育运动，他们的教练本可以做得更好吗？我想，你知道的，在我写的第二本书《为了对运动的热爱而执教》（Coaching for the Love of the Game）中，我想，你知道，我只是，我真的想对教练们强调——他们通常是，你知道的，自愿当教练的家长——只是提醒他们他们最初为什么要执教，为什么你一开始要给你的孩子报名这项运动。而且我认为我们作为家长、作为教练，往往会被职业体育和大学体育中对获胜、成功和结果的所有强调所分心。而且，你知道的，你们的听众都会对此有同感，那就是人们担心青少年体育在某种程度上已经变成了一个迷你的大学或职业体育赛场，家长、孩子和教练开始把过多的重点放在获胜、技能培养和，你知道的，在更高水平上比赛。
The reason that kids come out to play for the very first time is because they want to have fun. They want to interact with their peers. They want to learn and improve, but their focus is not on becoming a professional athlete. And so my, you know, my plea to coaches is to just remember that the reason they're, there is to have fun and to structure your practices and the feedback that you give and the encouragement that you give in a way that makes that child fall in love with that sport, or at least with physical activity in general, so that they will begin to adopt a lifestyle of being physically active.
孩子们之所以第一次出来踢球或玩耍，是因为他们想玩得开心。他们想与同龄人互动。他们想学习和进步，但他们的重点不是成为一名职业运动员。所以我的，你知道的，我对教练们的恳求是，记住他们去那里的原因是为了找乐子，并以一种能让那个孩子爱上这项运动，或者至少爱上一般的体育活动的方式来组织你的训练、你给出的反馈以及你给出的鼓励，这样他们就会开始采纳一种积极参与体育活动的生活方式。
You say in one of your books that winning does not matter one bit in youth sports, and I know you talk to coaches and groups of coaches. How does that idea go over with them? that's a good question it doesn't go over well with anybody i mean it's just so funny i was sitting at a i was sitting at just a youth baseball game the other day not the other day it's been a few years but my son was playing and they were getting crushed by this other team and i was sitting next to a parent and i just said well you know the good thing is that that winning and losing really doesn't matter you know it's we're out here to have fun and for them to get better and to enjoy the camaraderie of the
你在你的一本书中说过，在青少年体育中，赢球一点也不重要，我知道你跟教练以及教练群体交流过。这个观点在他们当中反应如何？这是一个好问题，这在任何人那里都反应不好，我的意思是这太搞笑了，前几天我正坐在一场——不是前几天，已经过去几年了——但我儿子在比赛，他们被另一支队伍打得落花流水，我坐在一个家长旁边，我只是说，嗯，你知道，好的一点是，赢和输其实真的不重要，你知道的，我们来这里是为了开心，为了让他们变得更好，并享受其中的情谊
of the game and to improve their skills and she looked at me with daggers in her eyes. Like, you have got to be kidding me. Of course winning matters. And I'm just thinking, wow, we're on completely different wavelengths because, you know, the truth is that the winning doesn't matter. I mean, if you have children who play youth sports, you may have a bunch of medals and ribbons in, you know,
比赛的乐趣并提高他们的技能，她看着我，眼睛里带着怒火。就像，你在开玩笑吧。赢球当然重要。我当时就在想，哇，我们完全不在同一个频道上，因为，你知道，事实是赢球并不重要。我的意思是，如果你有孩子参与青少年体育，你可能会有一堆奖牌和绶带，你知道的，
your child may have those in their room. But oftentimes they can't even remember what event those came from, you know? So it is tricky, but it is not the winning per se that matters. What matters is how we interpret the outcome of events for our children. And as adults, it behooves us to interpret them in ways that protect their self-esteem, that focus on effort, that focus on the things you can do to put yourself in a position to be successful, but don't focus on the outcome per se. if we can get all of our kids and one another to focus more on effort and by rewarding effort,
你的孩子可能在他们的房间里有这些东西。但通常他们甚至记不清这些奖牌和绶带是哪个活动得来的，你知道吗？所以这很棘手，但重要的本身并不是赢球。重要的是我们如何为我们的孩子们解读比赛结果。作为成年人，我们理应以保护他们自尊心的方式来解读这些结果，重点放在努力上，放在你能做的事情上，这些事情能让你处于一个能够取得成功的位置，但不要把重点放在结果本身上。如果我们能让所有的孩子和彼此都把重点放在努力上，并通过奖励努力，
by expressing that that's what we care about, and we can get all the kids on our team, if that's what we're talking about, to try their hardest, well, if they try their hardest, and I'm giving them good instruction as a coach, they will improve. And if they improve one day, they may be in a position where they win some games. But it's not the winning per se that matters. It's the process of teaching children and young athletes what they need to do to put themselves in a position to be successful. And that's in sports and in other venues in life as well. So what about on the other end of the spectrum?
通过表达这正是我们所关心的，我们可以让我们团队中的所有孩子——如果我们讨论的是这个的话——尽最大努力。好吧，如果他们尽了最大努力，而且作为教练我给他们提供了良好的指导，他们就会进步。如果他们进步了，有一天他们可能会处于一个赢得一些比赛的位置。但重要的并不是赢球本身。而是教导儿童和年轻运动员他们需要做什么来让自己处于成功位置的过程。这不仅适用于体育，也适用于生活中其他领域的活动。那么光谱的另一端呢？
And by this I mean there are teams where every kid gets a trophy just because he or she showed up. Is that a good idea? Is that something we should be doing for kids? Or are there other qualities that we should be rewarding the children for? Yeah, I mean, you worded that really well, Kim. I mean, if what you want to reward and to reinforce is just showing up, then great. You're doing the exact right thing. But if that's not enough, if showing up is just the first step, then you change your rewards
我指的是这样的球队：每个孩子都能得到一个奖杯，仅仅因为他或她露面了。这是个好主意吗？这是我们应该为孩子们做的事情吗？还是说我们应该因为其他品质而奖励孩子们？是的，我的意思是，金，你这话表达得真好。我的意思是，如果你想奖励和强化的只是露面，那太棒了。你做的事完全正确。但如果这还不够，如果露面只是第一步，那么你就得改变你的奖励方式，
in a way that recognizes the behaviors that you want to reinforce, right? So it's straightforward, positive reinforcement of activities you want to see and behaviors you want to see. So if effort is what we care about the most, then we talk to our hours. athletes about effort, and we reward effort both verbally as the coach and then maybe at the end of a season by giving out awards that reflect effort. It may be that it's a positive attitude we want to promote the most, and so maybe we have an award for the athlete who had the best positive attitude. I don't think there's any problem with every child giving an award, but I think the award
以一种认可你想要强化的行为的方式来做，对吧？所以很简单，就是对你想看到的活动和想看到的行为进行积极的正向强化。因此，如果我们最关心的是努力，那么我们就跟我们的运动员谈论努力，并且作为教练在言语上奖励努力，然后可能在赛季结束时颁发体现努力的奖项。也许我们最想弘扬的是积极的态度，所以我们可能会为拥有最佳积极态度的运动员设立一个奖项。我不认为给每个孩子都发奖有什么问题，但我认为这个奖项
should reflect the positive things that that child athlete did so that we encourage them to continue in that regard. Yeah. And showing up is important. I think it was Woody Allen who told us that 90% of success in life is just showing up, right? Yeah, that's right. Well, and I will say, you know, to your listeners who are coaches, if your kids aren't showing up, then you should start self-reflecting.
应该反映出那个儿童运动员所做的积极事情，这样我们就能鼓励他们在这一方面继续保持。是的。而且露面很重要。我想是伍迪·艾伦告诉我们，生活中的成功90%在于坚持露面，对吧？是的，没错。好吧，我还是要对你们这些身兼教练的听众说，如果你们的孩子没有露面，那么你们就应该开始反思了。
Why aren't they? If sports is meant to be fun, why in the world would they not be coming? Right? So make your practice so fun and so enjoyable that no child is going to miss it. You know? they're going to be there because that's where they want to be. So on this drive to win to making winning paramount, who's the bigger problem? Is it the coaches or the parents, or is the problem more society?
为什么他们不来？如果体育运动本来就应该是好玩的，他们到底为什么不来呢？对吧？所以，把你的训练搞得既有趣又好玩，让没有哪个孩子会错过它。你知道吗？他们会去那里，因为那是他们想去的地方。因此，在这种对胜利的追求、将胜利置于一切之上的推动下，谁才是更大的问题？是教练还是家长，还是说问题更多出在社会上？
I do think it's a societal problem. Now, there are a lot of groups that are trying to work against this, and so there's a lot of emphasis right now on coach education in giving coaches the skill sets they need so that they can, you know, work effectively with their athletes. and keep the focus where it should be on having fun, on developing their skills, on learning how to give effort, learning how to be a good winner and a good loser, learning how to be a good teammate, all of those types of things. But yeah, I do think it's societal because we see it not just in sport.
我确实认为这是一个社会问题。现在，有很多群体正试图与之对抗，所以目前有很多关于教练培训的强调，为教练提供他们所需的技能组合，以便他们能够，你知道的，与他们的运动员进行有效的合作，并把重点保持在应该关注的地方：玩得开心，培养他们的技能，学习如何付出努力，学习如何做一个好的赢家和好的输家，学习如何成为一个好的队友，所有这些类型的。但是是的，我确实认为这是社会性的，因为我们不仅在体育运动中看到这一点。
I remember when my kids were really, really little, and we were at the playground just talking to some parents, and the parents started talking about how they were getting their child enrolled in Kinder music and a little tots kind of. gymnastics program and a mommy and me soccer program. And these were like with three and four-year-olds. And it felt competitive. It felt like it was a race to success. And, you know, as a parent, you're thinking, oh my gosh, well, if I don't have them in Kinder Music and, you know, gymnastics and soccer and all these other things, violin, whatever it might be, then I'm behind and I'm doing my child a disservice. So I do think that it's not just sports. I think we see it in a lot of venues in society. And I
我记得我的孩子还非常小的时候，我们在游乐场和一些家长聊天，家长们开始谈论他们是如何让孩子报名参加幼儿音乐（Kinder music）、幼儿体操项目和亲子足球项目的。这些孩子大概三四岁大。感觉很有竞争性。感觉就像是一场通往成功的赛跑。而且，你知道的，作为一个家长，你会想，哦天哪，好吧，如果我没有让他们参加幼儿音乐，你知道的，体操和足球以及所有这些其他的事情，小提琴，无论可能是什么，那么我就落后了，我对我的孩子做了一件不公平的事。所以我的确认为这不仅限于体育。我认为我们在社会的许多领域都看到了这一点，并且我
I think it's this, you know, sense of a pressure to put our children in a place where they can be successful by exposing them to all sorts of activities. And then demanding success from them, I should add that. You know, if it's just participation, that's great. But if we start expecting higher and higher levels of success, we put enormous pressure on our children through these achievement-based types of activities. You've coached and you work with coaches. How do you teach kids how to lose and how do you teach coaches how to lose? Yeah, I mean, I know I've said this more than once, but I think it's really just focusing on process. You know, so if we lose a game or a match or an event and my athletes were trying as hard as they possibly could,
我认为这是一种，你知道的，一种压力感，通过让他们接触各种活动，把我们的孩子放在一个他们能够取得成功的地方。然后我要补充一点，对他们提出成功的要求。你知道，如果只是参与，那太棒了。但如果我们开始期待更高、更高水平的成功，我们就会通过这些以成就为基础的活动给我们的孩子施加巨大的压力。你当过教练，也和教练们合作过。你如何教导孩子们如何输球，你又如何教导教练们如何输球？是的，我的意思是，我知道我已经说过不止一次了，但我认为这真的只是专注于过程。你知道的，所以如果我们输掉了一场比赛、一场对抗或一项赛事，而我的运动员们已经在尽他们最大的可能去努力，
which I think most athletes usually do, and they were executing what I taught them to execute. then even if we lost the game, why do I care? Because the winning or losing of the game isn't in our control. Maybe we played a team that's much, much better than us. Maybe we just had some bad luck and couldn't finish on a goal or couldn't hit our shots that day. But if we're doing all the things that put us in a position for those shots to fall in the future,
我想大多数运动员通常都是这么做的，而且他们正在执行我教给他们执行的战术，那么即使我们输了比赛，我为什么要在乎呢？因为赢或输并不在我们的控制范围内。也许我们遇到了一支比我们优秀得多的球队。也许我们只是运气不好，那天没能进球或者没能投篮命中。但如果我们正在做所有那些能让我们在未来将球投进的事情，
then I should be thrilled, even if we lost. It's tricky, I agree. I have twin boys, and last year we played on a soccer team where we lost most games and we lost most games by a wide margin. And so every time we got in the car, I would talk to my boys and I would say, what did you do well today in the game? What did your teammates do well in the game? Where do we have room to improve?
那么即使我们输了，我也应该感到高兴。这很棘手，我同意。我有双胞胎男孩，去年我们加入了一个足球队，我们在大部分比赛中都输了，而且输得很惨。所以每次我们上车时，我都会和我的男孩们谈谈，我会说，今天你在比赛中做得好的是什么？你的队友在比赛中做得好的是什么？我们在哪些地方还有进步的空间？
And that was it. That's the end of the conversation because the teams they were playing were dramatically better than them. We could do everything right and we could still lose the game. So it's really important to think about the process. What did we do well? Where do we have room to improve? And that's true whether you win the game or you lose the game because maybe we played a team that's much weaker than us. Why should we be thrilled about a victory if we didn't do the things that we needed to do to be successful that are going to help us be successful when the competition goes up? So I think just helping coaches and athletes and parents to recognize the value of focusing on the process. What are the things we need to do to put us in a position to be successful? whether we're successful or not is oftentimes completely out of our control. And to put you on the spot a little bit, because you're the parent here with the kids who are in sports and you're applying your theories.
就是这样。对话到此结束，因为他们对阵的球队比他们优秀得多。我们可以把所有事情都做对，但我们还是会输掉比赛。所以思考过程真的很重要。我们什么地方做得好？我们在哪里有进步的空间？无论你是赢了比赛还是输了比赛，这都是真的，因为也许我们对阵的是一支比我们弱得多的球队。如果我们没有做那些我们需要做的事情来取得成功（这些事情将有助于我们在竞争加剧时取得成功），我们为什么要为一场胜利而欣喜若狂呢？所以我认为只是帮助教练、运动员和家长认识到专注于过程的价值。我们需要做哪些事情来让自己处于成功的位置？至于我们是否成功，往往完全超出了我们的控制。稍微把你推向风口浪尖一下，因为你是在场的、孩子在参加体育运动的家长，而且你正在应用你的理论。
Are they working? I mean, are your kids still playing sports? Do they still love what they're doing? Or are they the kids who switch around every few months? They just want to try something else? I mean, for my boys, they've stuck with soccer, despite literally being on a team for two to three years that had very limited success. This year, now they've had some success, and so now we have to talk about what that means too, right? So how do we interpret that? Does that mean you're done? Does that mean you don't have to work on your skills anymore? Of course not.
它们起作用了吗？我的意思是，你的孩子们还在参加体育运动吗？他们仍然热爱他们正在做的事情吗？还是说他们是那种每隔几个月就换来换去的孩子？他们只是想尝试别的东西？我的意思是，对于我的男孩们来说，他们坚持踢足球，尽管他们字面意义上待在一支两到三年内几乎没什么成功的球队里。今年，现在他们有了一些成功，所以现在我们必须讨论这意味着什么，对吧？那么我们如何解读这一点？这是否意味着你结束了？这是否意味着你不再需要磨炼你的技能了？当然不是。
And what's been fun to see with them is they just came back from a tournament where they were successful. And as soon as we got in the car, they said, well, we need to get back to our own personal skill training so that we can do better in the next competition. because here's the things that we didn't do well, even though we were successful. And so I think, yeah, I do think that as effective. So what's the connection between your research, what you're doing in your lab, and your work in youth sports and coaching? How do these fit together? Yeah.
看到他们身上有趣的是，他们刚从一个他们取得成功的锦标赛回来。一上车，他们就说，嗯，我们需要回到我们个人的技能训练中去，这样我们才能在下一场比赛中做得更好。因为以下是我们没有做好的事情，尽管我们取得了成功。所以我想，是的，我的确认为这很有效。那么，你的研究、你在实验室里做的事情，与你在青少年体育和执教方面的工作之间有什么联系？这些是如何结合在一起的？是的。
Yeah, thanks for asking that. I mean, I think that, you know, if you think about people who stay active into adulthood and beyond, there is something about being active that they found rewarding. And I believe that when we have the opportunity to have young athletes come to us in whatever sport it is, it is really the onus is on us as the coaches and the adults who are working with them to ensure that they have the most positive experience they possibly can. Because whether they choose to stick with soccer or they switch to swimming or they're playing tennis, it doesn't matter because the goal for me as a kinesiologist is to encourage people across
是的，谢谢你问这个。我的意思是，我认为，你知道的，如果你想到那些在成年甚至更晚时期仍然保持活跃的人，他们在保持活跃的过程中发现了一些有价值的东西。我相信，当我们有机会让年轻运动员来到我们这里——无论是什么运动——作为教练和与他们一起工作的成年人，我们真的有责任确保他们拥有他们所能拥有的最积极的体验。因为无论他们选择坚持踢足球还是改练游泳，或者他们在打网球，这都不重要，因为作为一个运动机能学家，我的目标是鼓励跨越
the lifespan to be physically active because I know the benefits that they'll receive from being physically active. So I think it ties together in a really clear way. It probably seems like there are different ends of some crazy continuum, but to me it makes really good sense because I want to encourage, I want to make sure that young athletes have a positive experience so that they are not turned off from sport and physical activity in general. What are you working on now and what do you think are some of the most interesting questions in your field at the moment?
生命历程的人们进行体育活动，因为我知道他们从体育活动中获得的益处。所以我认为它以一种非常清晰的方式联系在一起。这可能看起来像是某种疯狂连续体的两端，但对我来说它非常有意义，因为我想鼓励，我想确保年轻运动员有积极的体验，这样他们就不会对运动和一般的体育活动产生反感。你现在在做什么？你认为目前你所在领域最有趣的问题是什么？
Oh, yeah. Well, right now we have this large clinical trial that we're conducting at UNCG, where we're recruiting individuals who are 40 to 65 years of age and have a family history of Alzheimer's disease. So these individuals, because of that family history, have a greater risk of having Alzheimer's disease themselves. And so what we're doing is we're randomly assigning them to either exercise for a year,
哦，是的。嗯，现在我们在北卡罗来纳大学格林斯伯勒分校（UNCG）进行这项大型临床试验，我们正在招募40到65岁、有阿尔茨海默病家族史的个人。因此，由于这种家族史，这些个人患阿尔茨海默病的风险更高。所以我们正在做的是，我们随机将他们分配到进行为期一年的锻炼中，
and it's exactly like what I was talking about, Kim. It's a mix of aerobic exercise, walking, and strength training three times a week for a full year. Or the other group, we asked just to maintain their normal lifestyle. And they all came to us as relatively sedentary individuals. So we anticipate that the control participants will remain sedentary for a year. At the end of the year, we give them funds to support them joining their local YMCA and hope that they will start exercising at the end of the clinical trial. But what's really neat about this is that we anticipate that these individuals are going to see an improvement in their cognitive performance if they're in the exercise group,
这完全就像我刚才说的，金。这是一项为期整整一年、每周三次的有氧运动、步行和力量训练的组合。至于另一组，我们只是要求他们维持正常的生活方式。而且他们来找我们时都是相对久坐不动的人。因此我们预计对照组的参与者将在一年内保持久坐。在这一年结束时，我们向他们提供资金支持他们加入当地的基督教青年会，并希望他们在临床试验结束后开始锻炼。但这件事真正棒的地方在于，我们预计如果这些人在运动组中，他们的认知表现将会有所改善，
and that that improvement in cognitive performance is going to be supported by changes in brain structure and function that we'll measure with an MRI. And, you know, they'll get benefits at the end of that year. And then what we want to do and what we hope we do is that we give them the tools that they need to maintain their new physically active lifestyle going forward. so that ultimately we reduce their risk of Alzheimer's or at the very least delay the onset of Alzheimer's for them, hopefully buying them more years of quality of life with their family and loved ones. Well, Dr. Ettingy, I really appreciate your joining me today. This has been very interesting and hopeful instruction.
并且这种认知表现的改善将得到我们将用核磁共振测量的脑结构和功能变化的支撑。而且，你知道的，他们在这一年结束时会获得益处。然后我们想做的是，我们希望做的是，为他们提供所需的工具，以便他们在未来维持新的积极身体活动的生活方式。从而最终降低他们患阿尔茨海默病的风险，或者至少为他们推迟阿尔茨海默病的的发作，希望能为他们争取到更多与家人和挚爱在一起的高质量生活年。好的，埃廷吉博士，非常感谢您今天加入我们的节目。这非常有趣且充满希望。谢谢。您可以访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 以及任何您获取播客的地方收听《心理学热线》的往期节目。
And I feel like I need to go out and take a walk or ride my bike right now. Absolutely. Absolutely. Take somebody with you. Good advice. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我觉得我现在就需要出去走走或者骑自行车。绝对是的。绝对的。带上某人一起。好建议。谢谢。您可以访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方收听《心理学热线》的往期节目。
And if you're listening on Apple, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kandyan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您在 Apple 上收听，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 联系我们。《心理学热线》由莉·韦纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·坎迪安。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理协会。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。